欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课 第一小节 我们来讲一下关于如何去提升运营综合实战能力
这个板块非常非常的重要 是我们很多人都忽视的一个板块 同时呢
很多人做了很多年的运营都没有把这个板块弄懂 所以就会导致他可能做了一到两年或者是三年以上的运营
但是呢他的知识很混乱 同时他也不知道怎么样去规划和应用这些方法
所以就导致他做店铺很难拿到结果
每次的操作都是没有头绪 没有具体的一个思考方向的 那么通过这一节 我们就能够解决这些问题
让你用一年的时间就拥有别人三年的运营能力 掌握跨行业的应用能力
为什么我敢这样说呢 因为我见过太多太多一到三年
经验的运营 他们很多时候
知识他懂得很多 但是他不会应用
然后呢 他换个店铺 换个行业 或者是换个产品
就不知道
接下来我要怎么样去
规划和怎么样去
运营这个店铺了
所以说他就没有这种
跨行业的应用能力
通过我们这整个课程的学习 你一定能够
在短时间内
最短可能是一年时间内 就拥有了掌握跨行业的应用能力 所以说
这个
非常的重要 希望你重视起来
第1个板块就是
构建
我们的运营思维框架
拥有跨行业的应用能力
我们要从5个板块里面去
构建我们的运营思维框架
首先第1个板块就是平台规则
很多时候我们开始学习的时候
根本就不去了解平台规则 如果你不了解平台规则 是不是就不知道
怎么样去做
才能够满足平台 如果满足不了平台 或者是说
不符合平台的规则
那么是不是
他就不会给你流量 也就是你的流量分配会很少 甚至是没有
所以说你店铺就做不起来
第2个就是对一些
平台的
指标概念不理解
比如说曝光量 什么是曝光量 点击什么是点击 点击率 转化率
还有商机指数 意向商机 奥义加
点击站比等等 这些都是指标的概念 如果你对这些指标的概念都不理解
那么你在思考问题就没有一个很清晰的方向 也没有一个具体的一个明确的方法去
进行店铺的调整
第三个呢 就是流量思维
很多时候我们不理解
流量是什么 其实流量的背后就是人
人 你要理解这个人的
行为习惯 那么你需要拥有一定的思维 才能够
更好的去理解这些流量 理解了你才能更好的去
知道这个店铺要怎么样去操作
才能够达成你的目的 第四个呢 就是买家的思维 因为我们做店铺
比如说 我们设计的万物首页 详情页 是不是站在买家的角度去看
买家到底在需要什么 他们的想法和他们的行为 到底是什么
如果我们站在买家的角度去看 那么我们设计出来的万物首页 详情页 就更加符合买家的需求
就更加容易能够获得买家发来的询盘
和订单 那么第五个呢 就是
实战应用 也就是
我们很多人
学习了
前面这些全部都学了
都会了一点点
但是会的都不深
为什么会的不深呢
因为他没有去把前面所学到的这些知识
应用出来
如果你不把知识
应用出来 那么你对这些知识的理解
就很浅
同时呢 你的这些知识也没有
内化成为你的
具体的
技能
所以你必须直接应用这些知识
在
自己的实操当中
才能不断的去构建你的
思维
让你对这些知识有更深度的理解
才能够更加综合的应用
所以
实战应用一定要重视这个板块
所以呢
构建自己的运营思维框架就要从这五大板块去进行
搭建
那么我们在接下来的学习
或者是
在接下来的应用当中一定要
重视这些板块
再开始去操作就可以了
如果
按照这样的思路去学习
只要我们积累的
时间
足够长
知识足够多
那么我们的
知识就有一定的结构化
才能够
持续的
不断的迭代出更多新方法
普适于各种行业
也就是
当你上面这些知识越来越多了
那么你后面就会
产生更多的新的方法
去应用于
不同行业
这就是一种
支持
应用牵引的能力
那么最后面我们一定要牢记
基础规则
用逻辑去做运营
基于数据去做决策
构建一种属于
自己的运营底层思维框架
一定要牢记规则
不然的话我们是很难
做得出结果的
所以希望大家能够重视起来
并按照这样的思路
结合自己的实际情况和店铺的实际情况
去进行操作
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见